[Music]
hey sean what's up howard doss we are
still here cranking out podcasts we are
crime con in las vegas yeah so those of
you that watch these on youtube howard
and i are obviously in the uh the same
outfit so we have not filmed
one episode a week over the next four or
five six weeks or however many are going
to come out we're in the same stage
we're on the same stuff yeah we're just
knocking these out taking advantage of
of running into people here at crime con
that we uh
can can trick convince
lure whatever the word is that we can
get them up here to sit down in our
little studio that you and jason set up
yeah chris hanson kind of helps us on
some tricks to lure people in and it's
really paying off for us here turned out
for a great show for him yeah but you
know uh this is this is one of those
episodes you like we got a run and gun
cop
that's how i like them i know you know i
always like the stuff that's a little
bit more
the details the technical stuff of it
you like the cop stories i like cops man
i like i like the cops that are cops too
the gritty
as you said i just had a pause here and
how to word it you like the the the
the brain side analyzing things and and
things like that i like
guys that chase violent offenders that's
i guess maybe in a different aspect i
don't know if that makes sense but
that's my jam i think we both like both
of it we just have a tendency to
kind of lean a little bit further on the
other side but today we got a gentleman
with us mr phil waters and he has done
everything he's done a lot of stuff that
you've done except he's done in big
cities like houston he's worked in the
game tulsa is a good wait wait wait you
say he's except he's done it in big
cities well listen this is a town
brother okay so
i know houston obviously has millions of
people there especially in the metro
area but it's one of the misconceptions
people had about tulsa oklahoma is they
think and we'll get into it here with
phil he's actually from oklahoma or we
had no idea until he walked in here
today but
tulsa our police department has like 830
officers we're not one of these little
rinky dink ass agencies man houston is
well you insulted tulsa i mean you made
it you insulted my police department i'm
proud i like our time i like it all
love the tpd all right
so phil welcome today we're glad to have
you thank you i appreciate you all
asking me to be here no it's pleasure
um and phil as you can see by this
delicious
plastic cup it's not ideal but it is
what we're working with here that's got
what appears to be a
a beautiful brown elixir that's not iced
tea
it's actually another bottle that one of
the las vegas pd retired guys actually
brought us we did for a uh by the name
of ashton pak so this is one of their
bottles he came up we interviewed him
and he shared a bottle with us so
we're gonna
wrap up crime con with our interview
here with you and kind of sip on his
bottle a little bit more if that's all
right so cheers appreciate you being
here with us yeah cheers
all right asked i'm sorry i'm going to
have a very gracious obviously put the
brown water that i prefer on the table
oh he went out yeah he likes gentleman
jack and i was like well hell we got
some jack let's do some drinking well he
was he was telling a story from back in
the day before we hopped on here about
uh what did you say charlie pride or who
was it that was johnny paycheck johnny
no no no no no charlie daniel charlie
daniels hey there's another one so
somebody has sucked down some some jack
daniels and lo and behold here you go
there you go made it work all right phil
we asked this question everybody
how'd you become a cop
it was a calling would be the short
answer i had a real job before i became
a cop
i was a construction manager for u.s
home in houston texas
and
wanted to be
wanted to be the police
and
the opportunity was delayed for me so i
got out of the marines in 82
i married my wife
her family was from houston i did what i
said i would never do which was live and
work in houston texas but i still say
that i and i still don't live there i
want to qualify that but i ended up
working there so
it was
an opportunity presented itself to
become a reserve with the harris county
sheriff's office
so that's kind of the way i started and
i was having the best of both worlds
and the harris county sheriff's office i
think they're the second or third
largest in the country
so they had their own their reserve
program is like an old their own
separate police department
so i was working two or three nights a
week riding patrol working for free
but i was living the dream and
i was making 35 40 000
a year as a construction manager and
i
got to the point where the the oil
industry crashed the housing industry
crashed
and i had to make a decision usm was
offering me an opportunity to that
that's what they called them
opportunities
that if i was going to remain with the
company
i was going to have to move to either
garden city new jersey or baker fields
california and i went i don't think
those are viable options either
direction
so in the meantime i had a friend who
was a marine who was a captain of the
montgomery county sheriff's office and
they called me and offered me a job in
the midst of this turmoil here about
what am i going to do
so for a month i wasn't sure but for a
month i took the job and where's
montgomery county at this the county
seat is conroe conroe texas okay so
montgomery county texas
and
the
uh i worked night shift in the jail
from
7p to 7a they were two days on three
days off three days on two days off
and then i worked for a u.s home during
the day
damn you were busy that was crazy you
weren't sleeping no and i
did that for a month trying to decide
what what did i want to do and i wanted
to be a cop and it was a calling it was
just something that i
you know the lord led me to
and
so i went from making 35 to 40 grand a
year
to making 1600 a month as a deputy
sheriff in montgomery county and i
when i talked to my wife i said this is
what i want to do
she only asked me one question can we
pay the bills and i of course i lied oh
shit oh yeah
of course
and but i tell you what it was the
i i've never looked back i mean i've had
a
an awesome 33-year career i spent the
last 23 years a homicide detective of
the houston police department and it has
been the most fulfilling i i can't
imagine a better career or a better
time in my life
so you go from how do you end up going
from montgomery county
to transitioning later over to the
houston police department well i got
fired by the newly elected sheriff that
was the first transition
what was what was it was just cleaning
yeah yeah was it just cleaning the house
you know
we had a very
unique relationship i was
in the narcotics unit and he was the
commander as he called himself and he
worked for the da's office it was a task
force kind of set up
and you were trying to
kind of define the kind of cops that you
like to talk to well in
in our world in houston we would talk we
distinguish those people by you're the
real police or you're not that's it man
police
that's it
so we uh i say it man
phil i say it there's a lot of guys
in this listen we need all the different
types of police officers hands down we
need guys that are you that are murder
police you know the homicide guys we
need the guys during the gang units
which i think that's kind of where you
had a specialty at and we need the guys
that you know work the traffic and we
need the people that are doing the the
burger reports you need it you know
there's there's niches that are not for
me and just vice versa there are there's
stuff that i did that's not for other
cops for sure but you and i both know
and anybody out here that's in law
enforcement listening knows there are
also people that what i call play cop
you know they get to tell their friends
and their family that hey i'm a police
officer for houston or tulsa or wherever
it may be and they collect a paycheck
from that police department that says
they're a cop but they're they're not
doing real police paper police that's it
that's it and you know i joke or some of
the guys that i worked with we joked
that there were guys that should be
charged for embezzlement you know
collecting paychecks as a police officer
government right yeah just the fact that
they collect a paycheck as a cop man
should be get charged for embezzlement
so yeah but sorry go ahead well so uh
well i didn't mean to do that um
so the
net to answer your ques to answer your
question further your question but i
knew this was coming in terms of the
the uh the change the change in my life
at that time
and
i had already prepared for it so i had
applied
with dea and it had been accepted at dea
and knew where i was coming back to
and then i had applied at houston pd for
the lateral entry program
and so i i knew what was happening
and then i was
i got the the blue letter that we there
were 22 of us that were fired
immediately i mean like that
first of january 1993
as a result of this election so
i in fact i actually got screwed over by
two politicians in that same time frame
because
i had been accepted at dea
i was supposed to go to the academy in
the fiscal year 93 which starts in
october of 92 for the federal government
they took a hit in their budget so i get
a call and said
look you're going to be
going to the academy that that academy's
been canceled you'll be going to the one
that starts in february but okay cool
well if you all remember bill clinton
was elected president in november of 92
took the oath in january of 93 two weeks
later puts a federal hiring freeze on
and i turned 37 in august so that
screwed you you're too old yeah too old
so there's an age limit for a lot of
these federal jobs a lot of police
departments don't have an age limit it's
kind of like if you can pass the
physical and the city medical will look
at you and see if you're a liability for
injuries or something like that but
those federal jobs uh they they have an
agency
it is and then there's a mandatory
retirement at 57. yeah
so so that that was but you know what
like i said the lord puts you where he
wants you and
at the same time in fact we were in
hawaii in december celebrating our
wedding anniversary and i got a phone
call from hpd and said you'll be
attending the latter electric class they
just didn't know when
and so then in july of 93 i started the
lateral entry class at hpd lasted nine
weeks long
and from and i was a cod been a cop for
10 years by the time i started that so
i
went and i knew a lot of guys at hpd i'd
worked with them when i was in narcotics
and that kind of thing and the narcotics
guys want me to come to narcotics cite
buddies of mine in homicide they're
saying no you need to come to homicide
no our team's better right right exactly
right it was kind of like a draft right
and so
but i'd done the narcotics thing it was
a lot of fun really enjoyed it
and
i thought you know what i need to try
something a little different in the
homicide aspect investigations has
always intrigued me
and my
one of my mentors my good friend that
kind of ushered me into that i
he said it's the best job in the
building
and if it gets in your blood you'll
never leave it and i never did i didn't
want to promote i was a homicide cop and
that's what i wanted to retire as
yeah and you see that i mean we've got
legendary guys at my own police
department same type of deal they've
gotten in there and they were in there
until the end of their career or guys
that got in
did promote dave walker mike huff i mean
guys like that
another guy who never promoted by the
name of mike dance i mean he was in
there forever he's now retired
legendary homicide detective in tulsa
and
just as you were saying you get in there
it's in your blood the uh
solving these crimes finding these these
bad guys i mean it's just a generic term
helping these victims the families
um we've had guys that got in ended up
leaving they do promote
and
as soon as a corporal or sergeant or
lieutenant position something like that
opens up i mean they're right back in
there then they ride out to the end of
the career and that's guys like mike
huff and some of these other guys well
you have found um once you got into
homicide you found that you kind of had
a little niche you're pretty good at huh
[Music]
i had the desire to be the best
and i'm not saying that i ever achieved
that but that was my desire always to
learn something new every day
don't take anything for granted
and
develop a the ability to
not only communicate with the with the
bad guys but to communicate with the
families that have been so affected by a
crime of violence
and so that
that's kind of where i went in my career
and i was i was fortunate i had
great partnerships at the beginning of
it and then at the end of it i partnered
with a
who was my best friend in the department
at the time we'd gone through the
lateral entry class together
we were both intrigued with the art of
the interview
and we developed a curriculum that was
required training for anybody coming
into investigations at hpd and taught it
he continues to teach it
although he's retired and working for
another agency
and i teach it when i'm
requested to do so in fact i was
involved with the international criminal
investigations training assistance
program
through the state department and doj
and taught
national police of ukraine detectives
in
the interview
and in investigations so
well let's talk about the interview
that's that's really where you made your
mark this is when you sit down with
somebody and
you get them to actually tell the story
what kind of black magic do you use to
do that well i try not to use jedi mind
tricks okay but it happens but it does
happen every once in a while you've got
to pull it out of the toolbox right but
i would say that the
the
the first thing that i realized going
into homicide was that when i
it's clear that i'm employed by the
houston police department but that i
work for god
so there's no one that's going to give a
voice to these victims and their
families except for people that do what
i do
and or did
and that was always the frame of mind
which i had when i walked into the
interview room and i try to develop that
skill
there's a lot of guys that will tell you
know because they can shoot the bull
with you that they're going to be great
interviewers and that's just not
necessarily the case
so you have to develop
i teach in my classes talk about it's
not it's not rapport building because
rapport building is is shallow and it's
temporary so what you want to do is you
want to build a relationship
and
understand that everything that you do
through life is a relationship now they
may be shallow
short-term they might be long and very
deep but nonetheless no matter who you
who you meet and come in contact with
it's always a relationship
when you come out of the chute
doctor slaps you on the button says
welcome to the world that's a
relationship
so i just tried to carry that philosophy
on
through my career
and
developed
an empathy for people
and that's most important in the
interview room when you're talking to a
suspect i mean you're talking to
somebody who has taken another human
life by an act of violence
and
it's my job to get to the truth it's not
my job to develop
the charges that's decided by other
people
and
that's what i would tell them so my
first priority is to gain their trust
and
i have to do that by
being empathetic to where they are
and
having an understanding about
the three things we have in common
yeah
just not to deviate from what you were
saying but i i just recently was on a a
news show
and they were talking about
um false confessions right and you know
some some in the media you know when one
of these stories comes out um you know
they're hammering the police about it
and you know they highlight stories like
this is a
regular occurrence this happens and
we're just like listen there the number
of cases whether it's homicides or
people that confess to a shooting a
robbery or burglary and auto theft or
whatever it may be
that the false confessions when you look
at the totality of numbers is a tiny
tiny deal and you hit it right on the
head right there it's not a an
investigator's job whether they are
investigating any of those type of
crimes obviously homicide being at the
top of the food chain it's not to get a
confession because that person across
the table is sitting there it's to get
the truth right um so
it's i just want to make sure that
people understand that when a detective
like yourself or somebody sitting in
there you're not there just to get this
person right here to confess you're get
you're there to get them to tell the
truth or or a witness or you know
anybody else that's coming uh that
you're you know interviewing regardless
of who the interviewer is yeah howard
one of the uh things that you really
brought up was empathy right and in my
profession it's paramount if you don't
have empathy for being a nurse taking
care of people you can't can't do it i
tell people constantly my job has
nothing to do with medicine has
everything to do with people right
when you talk about empathy and
this is kind of hard for a lay person to
understand when you're an empathetic
person you can understand people's
perspectives even though you don't agree
with them for example a murderer
criminal someone like that you can see
them as a person which is tough to do
especially if you know the crime they've
committed but
did you find that that helped you gain
being an empathetic person helped you
gain that rapport with them almost
instantaneously it helps establish the
relationship and through the through the
through the course of the interview you
have to be
available
non-judgmental to share exactly to share
a little bit of yourself so we talk
about in our training
when i talk about training in the
interview process is uh the life lessons
stories that you have that you can share
with them it doesn't mean you're going
to be swapping spit with them at the end
of the story right but
but you share a little bit of yourself
and that
lets them know that you're not being
judgmental like you said howard and you
are
being empathetic to the situation they
find themselves in
and there are some people look i i
worked on 400 over 400 homicides in the
city of houston in 23 years
that doesn't include murder for hires
aggravated assaults
uh
kidnappings and and the other stuff that
comes with working homicide right
but of those 400 homicides at a 96
clearance rate which is heck yeah
yes
and
90 of those i gained confessions just to
use the word uh gain confessions in
those cases now some of those may have
been self-serving statements but that's
okay i'll take it
but it just goes to show that
if the
because body language is body language
you know
verbal behavioralist verb verbal
behavioral stuff physical stuff it's all
the same
but the approach of how you look at that
person sitting across from you
is what's going to at the end of the day
is going to be the payoff
okay so you said something very um
very intelligent earlier about the fact
that you said you wanted i've got to
write that down howard
what was that
very intelligent you want to learn
something new every day correct so we're
going to talk about you had a 96
clearance rate god
that's that's amazing right that's so
good let's talk about them four percent
though
now why didn't you clear those what did
you would you miss there because i'm
sure that you've thought about those
cases what did you not learn from those
the the
good news is
is that there were some of those cases
because of the work i did that were
cleared later by the detectives in cold
case that picked those cases up
so that's the good news now not all of
them not all of them of course
and
the best answer i can tell you is is
that i did everything
a possible that i could do to solve that
case but there are just some cases you
hit the wall and that's it
and i guess the thing i'm asking you
which is the one that kind of haunts you
that man i wish i could have done
something different in this interview
and
got this out of i run into people in my
line of work sean runs the people in his
line of work
they're not like us they're not human
they don't oh no you don't have the
ability to empathize with them because
you can't possibly
think like they do no and it's not so
much even thinking of it it's just
basically walking behind them and
looking through their eyes
those are the people that really worry
me those are the people that i can't
understand and those are those are the
tough ones
so did you have any of those cases well
i had the ones
if you if you're referring to the ones
that i was not able to close
i've had a couple there that you know
the the kind of the traditional
i knew who did it right and couldn't
prove it
just didn't have that one one
affirmative link that's a lot of gang
murders i mean i i said i mean
and not to cut you off but that's
i know from whether it's open shooting
cases we had where somebody didn't die
or some of the gang murders again tulsa
you watch first 48 i mean they have a
very high clearance rate in tulsa very
fortunate because as you and i both know
there are police departments around the
country that have horrific
i mean i'm talking like in the 30
percent oh yeah chicago yeah places like
that that's their closure rate on
homicides that have i don't know that oh
absolutely like yeah i mean it's insane
so when you're talking
excuse me you know him as an individual
having a clearance rate that higher
police departments that have very high
numbers um you know that have
very high uh numbers as far as
clearances when they are in a department
that has a lot of homicides i mean
listen if you're you're in broken arrow
oklahoma and you have two murders a year
and you close you have 100 clearance
rate that's a big difference between
well it looks good on paper it looks
good on paper yeah but when you're
talking an actual you know larger agency
that has a lot of bodies
um you know it's tough
but um
it is it's the gang related stuff
there's there's even just i said open
shooting cases not necessarily homicides
you know who did it
you just can't get that one person that
one witness that's going to help wrap it
up well you can't get the person if
you've got a talking if you've got a
victim yeah that's they're not gonna
they're gonna take care of it we'll go
take care of that later on exactly well
and i said it was kind of i don't i
don't know if the words your expertise
your niche or whatever you want you
worked a bunch of the gang stuff down
there
and you're right that's even you know
speaking for my own experience
when the
victim of this violent crime dies
a lot of time those are easier to solve
than the guys that are alive that refuse
to cooperate or like even if you're like
hey we know this is a suspect he's like
well i'm not testifying i'm not telling
you anything well the gang guys
my partner at the time and i we we had a
and really an incredible success rate
even with the gang stuff yeah now when
that all started was in
90 what was that 90 um
i guess it was 2005 right when katrina
hit mm-hmm that was about obviously
you guys got a large influx of people
tremendous they filled the astra yep
mayor white at the time yeah come on
over here we'll take care of you well of
course as they started filtering
into the area you know the katrians
started coming in
um
did you call it katrina that's i said
i've never heard that term you know we
got we got some of those in uh up in the
up in the tulsa area as well yeah we had
a better national guard term of
affection
absolutely
and when
we
as as
new orleans homicide rate
started to drop of course houston's went
up exponentially right and
of course we were dealing with i made so
many trips to new orleans i don't ever
want to see that city again and it was
no beignets for you oh it was
unbelievable and the
and i never saw a larger group of people
with the capacity to lie
about everything
and it got so bad that the judges in
harris county
got together with the district
attorney's office
and the heads of the law enforcement
agencies around houston
and determined that we were going to put
everybody that would not identify
themselves in jail
for failure to id
and totally yes
and people were getting put i mean left
and freaking right and then of course
we're working with we ended up getting
louisiana's databases
to see we can determine fingerprints and
who you guys had yeah
who do we have
and uh and you know one of the guys that
stands out
in my mind and that in that area and
that time frame was a guy named he
called himself be stupid
capital b appropriate
and
the gang situation in new orleans much
different than the gang situation in
houston
[Music]
they were
built on the wards in the areas that
they lived in new orleans
and in houston it's it can be built on
neighborhoods but you're talking about
crip and you know five nine bounty
hunters which is a blood
uh
uh
five deuce hoover crips you know that
are a crip group and and then you've got
these different variations
and they're all tied to some sort of uh
then you've got
la premiere you've got different stuff
you know the latino gangs and that kind
of thing so
really uh just a hodgepodge and a
melting pot of gang activity so that's
why the gang murder squad was formed
because at the time that
the the the katrician folks that were
coming over were getting in the fights
with the
traditional gangs in houston and the
gangs and the people that were killing
people from new orleans they were
indiscriminate and it was just
unbelievable and they're used to
napoleonic law
where if they don't make the case in 60
days
they get booted they they're they get
kicked to the curb
and these guys were coming over and
doing what they did
and the great intimidation of witnesses
in new orleans and that kind of thing
that's why these guys were getting
released they come to houston texas
they're sitting in the jail
60 days comes up and they're they're
counting down they're counting down that
61st day hits and they're going what
happened why am i still sitting here man
yeah and it's just welcome to houston
texas brother welcome to texas yeah
there you go man and uh so yeah it was a
it was a learning curve for us as
homicide detectives on dealing with a
different type of individual
during your 23 years there in homicide
again talking about like the
gang-related murders or you know
obviously you're a homicide detective
your own call you know body body happens
whether you're on the rotation or
however it comes comes up um what's one
of the cases
that
obviously every single one of them has
meaning there's a victim there's a
victim's family and things like that but
kind of one of the ones that just i
don't know if i use the word that hits
home more
or
uh
you know you had you had you know you
and your partners had more drive on it
was more of the community was a part of
it you know something like that that
just really stuck out to you even
looking back now well sean that's a
great question
and i would answer it this way
again well and i don't want to catch
again i don't want to diminish any of
them every single one of them so you'll
i think you'll
you'll understand my answer then with
what you just said
what i realized
in that 23 years of working homicides
it didn't make any difference if you're
a crack whore in the ditch
or if you're a socialite living in river
oaks which is the exclusive section of
of houston
that person
was someone to somebody
they mattered
so the
drive to
close those cases find the right person
who's done the wrong thing
and bring a better measure of justice
and
hopefully some peace
for the families of the victims
was the drive
so i i
there are certain cases that stuck to me
of course only because of the nature of
the case itself but in terms of a drive
to
so i hit every case
determined that i was going to close it
every one of them i don't care
i don't care who it was well and i'm
glad you said that because it's uh
obviously there's you know whether it be
in the media or the social media and
obviously policing such a huge topic and
i've tried to explain that to people i'm
like
we in the gang unit that i was in you
know
you and i don't know each other today's
our first day meeting each other i was
in the game for 14 years in tulsa as a
supervisor for that unit obviously we
worked all the gang-related shootings we
worked hand-in-hand with our homicide
unit on gang-related murders and things
like that and i try to explain to people
it's like listen we don't care that that
call comes in and we get up at two
o'clock in the morning to go out there
and work we work that thing just as hard
if it's a a shooting
we work just as hard for someone in this
community as we do when someone in the
other side of the city it's the same
thing obviously if it comes to closure
or arrests are made or in convictions
part of it's part of the court system
the other parts is how cooperative are
are our victims or our witnesses that
that's the deciding factor it's not
going to be you or me that's oh man i'm
i don't care about this case i'm not
working it any more difficult but during
the career
during my career
um there was one deal it was on a sunday
morning
this is still when the bubble caprices
were around you know and those are uh oh
yeah those were a great bag we called
them shampoos it was the same thing when
i came on you know everybody i mean i
started in obviously later in my career
than you but i came on a 97 and you know
you had guys that are still driving the
old you know early 80 cutlasses and the
box caprices right all that fun stuff
but
um
there had been a shooting the night
before that we had gotten called out
about uh some gangsters shot another
rival gangs guy got shot nobody's
cooperative
uh fast forward to the next morning and
one of these the the suspects from the
shooting the night before rival gang
wearing a baby blue bubble caprice you
know a shamu type caprice
well these gang members that were
neighborhood crips see who they think is
a hoover crip and
it turns out to be four kids that are
actually coming from church and they're
just driving a baby blue caprice that
matched the description of the night
before
so they see these kids up at a
convenience store
um close to one of these neighborhood
crips homeboy's houses and they run over
there and get a chopper they get they
grab a rifle and then pull up next to it
and the guy leans out the window just
starts unloading
and one guy loses an eye another guy's
paralyzed one guy's killed
another guy shot through the lungs and
one guy somehow makes himself tiny and
gets down between the seat and
underneath you know the floorboard and
somehow doesn't catch around
and it was just a horrific case we get
called in at like 10 o'clock in the
morning on a sunday
and
we've worked every single case the same
and still did up until i retired but
these were
kids
that were coming home from church right
you know they had they were just
mistaken for rival gang members and we
ended up getting everybody that day we
recovered the rifle we ended up getting
you know catching a guy up short and uh
it took a short time later you know
within the week or two or something like
that us and the fugitive warren squad we
tracked down the actual trigger man that
was involved in that what was in the age
of the shooters uh he i remember his
name was uh vincent aj aka or i'm sorry
not vincent aj's name was his street
name was venom was this kid's name um he
was
18 maybe so he's right in the same age
same age group they're all the same age
group yeah you know he was convicted and
he's in prison for the rest of his life
but it's one of those it was early on in
my time in the gang unit and when i
retired last year it's still one of
those cases that just always stuck out
and i can remember probably almost every
single right shooting murder case that
we went out on but those are the ones
that just when you look back on a career
and you go man i'm glad that the guys
that i worked around with
chased you know these guys responsible
for that well the work in those those
gang those gang cases are are
always a challenge
only because of the culture right within
the gangs it's you know you don't talk
to the police and all that stuff a lot
of them
they do but you know but what i've what
i have found is is you treat everybody
with dignity and respect
and there's
three things we all have in common that
allows
at least in my career and this is what i
teach allows us to do that
and
it crosses all boundaries of race creed
color religion
culture it doesn't it doesn't make any
difference what flavor you are
if we
remember
that we
three things we all have in common even
guys from arkansas jesus uh we've got uh
we all want to be loved
we all want to be respected
and we all want to take care of those
who love and respect us we just make
different choices about how we
accomplish those three things yeah spot
on and that gives you the ability to
anybody that will apply that gives you
the ability to to speak to
in our context in that interview room
with somebody that you have absolutely
zero in common with and
uh i know some of the gang guys we had a
guy named d loke you know they've always
got the street vernacular right be
stupid right exactly
i mean the do wrong do dumb well you
name it
he was a houston turd you know he was uh
he was a he was a
he was an og
the yog young original gangster
uh for the five new super crips and
they've been involved in a deal where
they're going to do a punishment thing
on one of their guys and blah blah blah
and they they ended up
um
killing some people but anyway uh long
story short i had him up in the
interview room and
treating him with dignity and respect
and so forth and so on and
and i asked him names are important so i
asked him what do you want me to call
you
and uh he said d look was fine that was
fine
and
uh i said well i appreciate that and i
said i'll be right back and i'm gonna
i'm gonna come in here and talk to you
for a little bit
and he said to me uh he said well mr
waters he said i know
i i know you were gonna come in and and
talk to me and i know i was going to
have to come down here and talk to you
because because because you're you're
homicide you're like above hpd yep and i
said like look at that man i said true
that yeah then i walked out and i came
back in we had a real nice conversation
so again you treat picking you know
people with dignity and respect and
you'd be amazed at uh at the
communication and relationship you can
have with them
i was actually just here at crime con
somebody asked that question i've been
asked before like you know
ended up in doing some of this media
stuff like weren't you ever worried
about when you were sat on the streets
dealing with people and i said man
listen
if you're a cop
you know there's
this mute this weird i guess mutual
respect probably a lot of people don't
understand between police and gangsters
you know there really is and it's like
man if you're not
if you're not beating guys up
if you're not stealing
dope or money from them if you're not
planting dope on them
they it's the you know it's the game
they understand hey they're bad guys
they know we're doing our job they're
doing their thing it's the cat and mouse
game and it's like long as you don't
you don't belittle them when you talk to
them you don't talk about their dead
homeboys you know in that way when you
have to sit down in a uh you know an
interrogation room or you catch them up
short even something as simple as you
stop them on a car stop and it's an
x-con you catch with a gun you know and
he's like you know what i've already
been to prison i don't want to do this
shit again
and you know as long as all because you
do you interact with a lot of the same
guys your
witness to one murder is going to be a
suspect in another or a victim in
another so you get to know a lot of
these type of people
but just as you're talking about as long
as you treat these guys well
um
it's it's beneficial at some point down
the road more times than not oh it is
absolutely absolutely is yeah and listen
i also want to say i know i said the the
the murder suspect his name was venom
i'm blank on his real name that's his
street name i mentioned i mentioned a
vincent aj he was actually the victim of
a homicide a gang-related deal so i just
don't want to make sure there's any
confusion there yeah well what's
interesting to me about all this is the
integrity that you guys are showing i
think the public needs to understand
that as a police officer there's a
there's a level of integrity you have to
have and that integrity kind of i guess
the best way to define integrity is
what you do when nobody's looking right
like you go into an interview room
nobody's in there there may be a camera
on or something but you go in there with
that respect you go in there and you you
treat your suspect with
the integrity that you have and expect
them to return that to you
usually you get pretty good results
obviously yours is just 96 percent i
mean you could have done a little bit
better but
that's kind of we tried it we tried and
i think the public misses that i think
they miss that
in order to wear a badge you have to
have a level of integrity well you know
the the the
cops are held a higher standard as they
should be hell yeah absolutely no no no
as a nurse hell yeah no qualms about
that and i can tell you that
the average
citizen comes in contact with a police
officer with law enforcement in some
capacity like two and a half times in
their lifetime i don't know where that
half comes from it's a short police
officer i'm not sure what that's all
about but
about
two and a half times in their lifetime
and
their
feelings
or understandings or
opinions about law enforcement are going
to be based
off of that primarily on that but then
the rest of that influence is going to
come from where what they see on
television and that's going to come from
television shows from media whatever
that is going to be
and
we all know especially in today's world
uh
the the
skewed
uh view of police officers that is based
on a false narrative
is is really really uh upsetting
and
these guys and gals that are coming into
law enforcement now god bless them
if this had been the the state of
affairs when i was a cop started being a
cop 35 38 36 years ago
i wouldn't have joined up for that kind
of stuff
yeah you know it's it's a uh
they're being called and they're and
they're coming forward and they're doing
it although the the recruiting efforts
around the country are so they suck i
mean it's just terrible and then you get
the guys that just come in and want to
do a win a paycheck
and those are the guys you know those
are the paper cops that
you know they don't have any passion
about this i think yeah i mean hell
listen there's a uh there's some
social media accounts out there that you
know that i follow um police related
post a lot of good stuff they'll find a
body cam you know a dash cam video and
incident that's happened and they kind
of break it down looking at the tactics
that were used and the safety and stuff
like that but
you know there's another one that's out
there right now it's called survive
policing and i don't know who's running
it but this guy was clearly a cop in a
decent agency he knew the job you know
the right way and he kind of calls out
these these cops that are on here doing
fucking tick tock videos you know while
they're at work and that's yeah that's
what i'm saying it's like they're just
all about they want to be social media
influencers as police and it's like it
is and thank you that's exactly it he
calls him out on it and you know and
it's it's
you know and i know they talk about
interacting with the public it's like
man that that's not what being a cop
is is being on social media posting
pictures of yourself all the time doing
that stuff self promotion no that's
exactly what it's idiotic it is and it's
you know and then i've diminishes the
professionalism of the body i've looked
at some of the people that are doing
this and that you know
you could see their patching and you'll
find out what agency they're working for
and it's some rinky-dink agency that has
no crime and it's like come on man
i got the chief involved you know i mean
yeah the chief you know
well so all right so uh
you retire from the houston pd
you obviously stay very active you're
out here one of the speakers at crime
con what are you doing these days well i
retired on december 30th of 2017. on the
first of january 2018 i opened up a
private investigation security company
and i'm now
gosh four and a half years later i'm now
the president and ceo of kindred spirits
investigations and security inc kindred
spirit sounds like a liquor store
you know well it has a lot of honey it
has a lot of connotation can you hook us
up with some allocated whispers i can
find it for you i guarantee you i'll
find you whatever brown water you have
all right i like brown water
it likes us too
um so what exactly are you guys out
there doing i mean uh you know i don't i
see your beautiful business card here i
do
everything um
[Music]
any type of investigation i've got some
great resources i've got some guys that
that some operators that i can bring in
when i don't have that area of expertise
if it's a fraud investigation i've got
guys that i can bring in that will do
the fraud investigation and i'll they'll
brief me on it so that i can go to the
client say here's what we're here's what
we're coming up with
and then if we have people suspects we
did a corporate uh internal theft thing
for a freight company
then i come in
my guide does all the
bean counting
found out that they had stolen
collectively among these five people
over a quarter of a million dollars
in brown liquor
well i don't think that that may have
been a celebratory part of stealing the
money yeah but they
um when it came down to it then it was
time to interview them so i went in and
brought my guy that knows the technical
stuff
and uh i conducted the interview with
him and we got we interviewed five
people we got five confessions
fantastic how can anybody find you out
there if they're looking for
whether it's you on their podcast uh you
want to hire you know your company for
some of the investigative work you're
doing and so forth they can go to
www.kindredspiritsinvestigations.com and
that's my website uh
tells about myself and then it tells
about the the the services that my
company offers
phil it's been a pleasure it has been
awesome i love it we like having a drink
with you we like the integrity i damn i
damn well like the empathy man that's
the thing that the whole reason we do
this podcast is kind of humanize cops
and shit you're a good human man well i
appreciate that i'd really do howard
thank you congrats on your career all
right thank you very much cheers all
right buddy
i kind of finished
the water so there you go all right at
least it was the water and not this
he did that earlier